according to the CDC each year in the
United States about 264 000 cases of
breast cancer are diagnosed in women and
about 2400 in men so what are the
symptoms and early signs of breast
cancer I'm Dr Jordan Wagner you may have
seen my Dr ER YouTube channel I am a
board-certified emergency medicine
physician and October marks breast
cancer awareness so here are eight early
signs of breast cancer to look for
number one a new lump or mass although
most breast lumps are not cancerous a
painless hard mass that has irregular
borders may be more likely to beat
cancer number two changes in feeling a
change in the way your breast or even
your nipple feels is something to pay
attention to if you have swelling pain
or tenderness even if no lump is felt
make sure you get it checked by your
doctor number three if your breasts or
your nipple changes in size number four
skin dimpling they say this can kind of
look or resemble an orange but any sort
of dimpling it's actually called pewde
orange just to be aware number five
nipple retraction in other words if the
nipple suddenly turns inward pay
attention to this number six changes in
the texture of the skin of the breast
areola or nipple for instance this could
mean that the nipple or breast skin is
red dry flaking or even thickening
number seven nipple discharge or fluid
coming out from the nipple that is not
breast milk number eight any sort of
breast or nipple area paint although in
many cases of early breast cancer there
may not be any pain you should always
see your doctor about any breast pain or
any other changes that you notice that
do not go away remember symptoms vary
from person to person but knowing how
your breasts look and feel normally is
important conduct regular self-exams
have regular screening tests and
mammograms that way you are aware of any
changes in your breasts all right I'm Dr
Jordan Wagner and shout out to nucleus
medical media for their awesome video
library and Graphics this video was a
collaboration between them and Dr ER
YouTube channel thanks so much for
watching and stay healthy my friends